nubes de ceniza caliente de 15 km de
altura
el monte semero en Indonesia entró en
erupción una vez más enviando lava por
la montaña y cubriendo los pueblos
cercanos de ceniza caliente unas 2000
personas se vieron obligadas a huir
ahora llueve en mi pueblo y no se ve
nada llueve ceniza volcánica A dónde va
ahora
No lo sé lo más importante es subir del
pueblo para salvar a mi familia Esta
última erupción en la isla Indonesia de
Java comenzó casi a las 3 de la
madrugada hora local del domingo y las
labores de búsqueda y rescate están en
marcha las autoridades se elevaron el
nivel de alerta del volcán a 4 el más
alto que existe ante el temor de que se
produzcan más estallidos de nubes
calientes flujos de lava y
desprendimientos de escombros volcánicos
se advirtió a los residentes que
mantuvieran una distancia de 8
kilómetros del volcán y los evacuados
fueron trasladados a refugios
cuando sea seguro podemos pedirles que
vuelvan a sus casas pero si todavía no
es seguro tienen que quedarse en
nuestros refugios
la última gran erupción del monte semeru
hace un año mató al menos a 51 personas
el volcán es uno de los casi 130
volcanes activos de Indonesia y es el
más alto y uno de los que más registra
actividad
el sábado Java también se vio afectada
por un terremoto de magnitud 6,1 menos
de dos semanas después de otro terremoto
mortal que mató a más de 300 personas
el archipiélago se encuentra en el
cinturón de fuego del Pacífico por lo
que los terremotos y erupciones
volcánicas como estas son habituales